welcome to space engineers yes it is
basically minecraft in space but there's
no shame in that minecraft you build
space engineers you build and fly and
most importantly you wage war with the
recent add of multiplayer and survival
mode the game has made a milestone the
arrival of survival makes mining crucial
creep into a hollowed-out asteroid and
set up a mining operation or coasts into
a ship graveyard and start scavenging
maybe you don't have time to mine and
you just want to build utilize creative
mode and let your imagination babies fly
set up bases ships scenarios whatever
you want the best part is being able to
share it with the community as well as
getting to see what they've been up to
case and point I begin playing people's
servers both of them were bland about to
call it a night and then I see Star Wars
and all caps star wars is easily the
best sci-fi known oh my god is that of
bespin cloud car and that's an x-wing
and a y-wing and a t16 skyhopper I used
to bullseye womp rats in that thing I
politely express my appreciation and to
which they reply want to see a Star
Destroyer yeah yeah I'll take a look at
that holy God
engine room control tower x-wing hangar
which I let slide we have another Star
Destroyer do you want to see it yes Wow
couple friends and I built the Normandy
in mass relay do you want to see it yes
[Music]
ah you as you can see this is space
engineers it's not just the game it's
the community that makes a sandbox like
this so incredible and from here on it's
just going to get better
[Music]